this is a DNA model printed from the pdb
101 website this is a simple version
where you can write in your own base
pairs in the white spots there are two
kind of lines on this version there's
solid and dotted we're going to fold the
solid line like a mountain so the lines
are visible and the dotted lines are
going to be inside like a valley so
they're hidden we're going to start with
the two edges of the solid lines take
them and fold like a mountain and those
are going to be your back bones and do
the same thing in the middle
you should get almost a square shape now
from this and now we're going to do the
dotted lines fold like a valley on the
edges and then in the middle and this is
the shape you should get when it's
flattened out and then we fold it in
it's a smaller version of what we just
had now we're going to take the back
bones the edges and we're going to
flatten them out completely and now
we're going to fold diagonal lines the
solid lines like a mountain again and
the dotted lines like a valley
keep pressing down so it keeps the shape
as you go
now if you go all the way down this is
the shape you're going to end up with
and if you pull it up like this and
straighten out the backbones
you should end up with a right-handed
double helix and if you tape shovel
together you'll get a longer chain and
you can use the more complex version
with the base parents already filled in